I hate intros Mike your academia's
season two we kick things off the day
after the villains attack on you way in
season one jump on over to the students
of class 1a where we learn about the
upcoming you a sports festival from the
crippled Eraserhead
we find out a little bit of lore about
you to the daka who wants to be a hero
for money so that she can help her
family also that she was freaking
adorable as a kid me 30 a goes to have
lunch with all my where he's told by all
might that the festival is his chance to
make his first big impression on the
world Yepez owed to with the sports
festival just around the corner all the
other classes come to check out their
competition in class 1a leaving taboc
you go to stir things up with basically
everybody by calling them extras which
technically is just accurate amongst the
crowd is heat oshi sheen so who didn't
make it into the hero course and was
placed in general studies instead we
also meet Ted statuettes tetsu who is
passionate and loud like pretty much
everybody else in the show the festival
finally rolls around and all the
students from the hero course general
studies support course and last the
Nerds from the business course take the
field the first event is a four
kilometer obstacle race with all the
students participating when the race
starts students are cut off by the
robots use in the entrance exam from
season 1 go to low key phrases that man
passes through taking the lead episode 3
we find out that Kara she man test a to
Ted sets you have near identical powers
and help dispose of the robots since me
DoDEA can't control his power yet he
grabs part of a robot in hopes that it
helps him out later the second obstacle
is the fall where may hots makes her
appearance and uses her beloved
inventions to cross the canyons the
third obstacle is a minefield that slows
everybody down allowing media to finally
catch up Bakugan thought loki are in the
front fighting with one another while
media digs up a bunch of mines and uses
the shield to detonate them all at once
he uses the explosion to propel him into
the lead where he detonates even more
mine slowing down pakka go and throw
final stretches close between the three
of them but authorities ends up coming
in first which normally you would think
is a good thing until the remaining
forty two contestants find out that the
second event is a cavalry battle where
they are given points based off of the
position they finished in the obstacle
race since me though dia finished in
first he's worth 10 million points which
makes him an obvious target to all the
other students episode 4 the total
points of the team members are added up
in contestants wear a headband
indicating the point value the objective
is to take other teams advanced and
accumulate points but you can't
intentionally make them fall so all the
students start breaking up into teams
mute audio teams up with roodaka
a skater to join as well but he turns
him down because he wants to compete
with me Dottie and not follow him so
they are forced to settle with hot samay
in Tokyo me as the other two members in
the beginning of the event a lot of
teams start get me tortilla because of
the high point value so they are fleeing
with the jetpack that hots may hat
meanwhile people start noticing that a
lot of headbands have gone missing and
the one responsible NATO monomer takes
balk who goes headband as well he then
makes the mistake of taunting vodka go
shifting all that crazy pent-up
aggression Baku go has for me daughter
yet over to Monomoy nana the last seam
Authority comes face to face with Totoro
Kees team episode 5 well Totoro Keys
team is going for me dodea a couple of
other teams have the same idea so Totoro
he freezes them and takes a quick detour
to relieve them of some easy headbands
now they set their sights back on me go
to you who's jetpack had stopped working
and I've been cornered meanwhile baka go
and Monomoy face up while mana my uses
his ability to copy other people's works
to fend off baka goes advances back over
to me Bonilla who has successfully
dodged Totoro Kees attacks for five
minutes now in a small space so eda is
forced to use a secret move to secure
the 10-million point headband after
losing the head of anomie DoDEA's team
panics and charges to get it back
Todoroki has sworn to never use his left
side flames but he subconsciously
activates them because he feels so
overwhelmed by midoriya back over to bak
you go who successfully takes two
headbands off of Monomoy but isn't
satisfied and continues to break through
their defenses taking all of their
headbands Mew 30 is able to control one
for all and swipe through total Rocky's
defenses grabbing one if the headbands
but he misses the 10-million point
headband in the end the top four teams
me 30 yet Totoro Ibaka go and she's so
advanced to the next round
yeah the sewed six while talking to
total rookie midoriya finds out that the
reason he doesn't use his fire quirk is
because he resents his dad the number 2
hero endeavor endeavor for started Okies
mom into merge just so he can make a
child strong enough to be all my we also
learned that the scar on Totoro Keys
face is from his mom throwing boiling
water on and because she is repulsed by
his left side anyways back over to the
festival where the remaining 16
competitors are gonna fight 1v1 in a
single elimination style tournament
Oceana and shout out both drop out
because they can't remember the cavalry
battle so they don't feel like they
deserve to be in the finals Tessa suit
at statue replaces one of them and the
second replacement is ebody she Ozaki
for the first round authority has placed
up against xin so when the battle starts
xin so begins insulting go Judah which
procs a response from Edo to you after
me daughter yells he suddenly freezes
like he's in a trance Yepez owed seven
shoot shows cork is brainwashing but he
needs the victim to answer him before he
can use it he uses his brainwashing to
make me talk
you start to walk out of bounds right
before he steps out and loses he
hallucinates the former heroes who had
won for all before him this course has
had just enough to break his fingers
using one for all and this snaps him out
of the brainwashing from then on he
avoids talking and bum-rush is shin-soo
they throw hands for a bit before me
though do judo tosses him out of bounds
Ruth Odia tells all my about the vision
he had in all my says that it happened
to him too so don't pay too much
attention to it in the next match Seto
is slightly mismatched he gets cocky and
gets immobilized in a mountain of ice
Episode II the third matches between
kami naughty and she Ozaki she Ozaki
uses her vine quirk to block his
electrical tax and restrains him winning
her the match the fourth matches between
IVA and hot sameba really hot to me just
wants to use this opportunity to go
hyper will make a sellout for her
support items after her sales pitch he
throws the match in Edo wins the fifth
match is between the side characters
said nobody really cares about Aikido
and now Yama where a Cheeto wins with a
solid uppercut match number six is Tokyo
me squaring up against ya go to zoo
Tokyo Yami relentlessly attacks with
dark shadow and yeah go to zoo ends up
out of bounds before she can even
retaliate the two hard bros Tet sets you
in Kedah Shima through hooks ana ends up
being a draw so when they regain
consciousness they're gonna arm wrestle
to decide the winner man did the last
scene Otto Dhaka is getting ready to go
up against baka go for the final match
of the first round episode 9
relentlessly attacks buck you go trying
to touch him to activate her quirk but
he fends off the assault with explosions
the whole time doing this she's storing
up more and more debris above him and
launches her surprise attack when she
springs her trap he blows away all the
debris and even though she tries to
continuing after her plan failed her
body collapses making Baku go the winner
back over to the hard burrows where Kid
Ashima wins out armwrestling in the
second round he thought he has first up
to fight again and he's against the
newly formed rival Toto Doki episode 10
the fight between Midori and Totoro key
turns into a battle of fatigue with
Totoro key refusing to use his flinch
but his body can't keep producing guys
on the other hand mediodía is holding up
the continuous ice attacks by breaking
his fingers to deflect the ice
eventually he's wreaking his fingers and
it gets to the point where he can't even
move them so he breaks his thumb on his
cheek we get some flashbacks of coated
rookies mom going crazy which is when
she burns Totoro key with the boiling
water after that endeavor had her
hospitalized which is why Totoro key to
test his dad and his power so much
eventually the fight gets to the point
where Totoro key is forced to use his
flames but he still doesn't entirely
accept them after a massive clash Midori
is unconscious after being hurled out of
bounds making Totoro key the winner
episode 11 recovery girl says that she's
not gonna heal wounds like this again so
he needs to learn to control his power
back over to the matches socio Zach Diaz
ran out of bounds by Ada and Tokyo me
easily knocks out a Cheeto kid eeschema
goes up against baka go and ultimately
gets too fatigued from continuously
blocking his explosions total Loki is
back to not using his planes but he
still manages to be eda and thus emmys
doko Yami loses the baka go because dark
shadow is countered by the light from
the explosions after the fight EDA gets
a call from his mom explaining that his
older brother Ted say who he looks up to
was gravely injured by a new villain in
the last scene we get a look at the hero
killer stain who was approached by Koga
T requesting a meeting with him yeah the
so 12 in the finals between Totoro ki
and Bakugan auto rookie launches ice
attacks but baka go blows up the ice
with his explosions well coogo comes out
and with everything he has in total
rookie comes close to using his left
side but decides in the last moment not
to and he loses the match because of it
black Hugo is pissed because he won
without todo dokey giving it his all so
midnight has to use her aroma to put him
to sleep after that he's restrained and
forced to take the medal after the
finals toto dokie still isn't sure how
to feel about his power so he decides to
go see his mom who's still
institutionalized from when she threw
water on him episode 13 the students
find out they're gonna be interns under
various Pro heroes who sent them
individual offers most of the episode is
that making up hero names for their
internships and deciding where to go we
find out that UTA's brother has no
feeling in his leg so he can't continue
doing hero work who wants a dad to take
up his hero name Ingenium to carry on
his legacy
Midori gets an offer from grant Serena
who is an old friend so all meit's
predecessor and knows about one for all
eight on the other hand had picked an
agency in hoe City which is where his
brother was attacked which Eraser had
found strange because he got better
offers episode 14 mitho day he goes to
see gran torino who at first looks like
he's dead but really he just spilt some
food he spars with gran torino who's
bouncing off the walls all over the room
and takes me dodea down without any
trouble Stane meets with chigan Akio is
wanting him to join the league of
villains but stain refuses because they
pretty much want to kill everybody
meanwhile all the other students are off
on their internships including total
rookie who went to work with his dad and
ever at his agency Methodius training
starts to bear fruit when gran torino
makes him realize that instead of
focusing one for all in a single part he
should maintain it throughout his entire
body episode 15 Oh might meets with this
police friend now masa su kachi who
talks about the gnome who they detained
on the attack on usj from season 1 after
learning from sakauchi that somebody has
the ability to give quirks all my quest
if that man is on the move again after
talking to staying for a while she could
knock he decides that he doesn't want to
work with somebody like this so stain
has returned to host before he goes
stain takes a second to explain that
here's just one money these days so by
killing heroes he hopes to reform the
system shiko dachi doesn't like him so
he lets loose three no moves on the city
to hunt down stayin and killin me thirty
is passing through hosts to go to
another city with gran torino when their
train is hit by a fight between one of
the no moose and a hero gran torino
tells me though divas stay on the train
and goes to fight the nomu eva goes off
by himself hunting for stayin and finds
him attacking the hero native episode 16
gran torino is fighting against the know
me when endeavor shows up and burns the
know move with his flames meanwhile
mediodía finds out for manual that EDA
went out by himself so he goes looking
for him jump on over to eita who gets
dumped stirred by stain but me thorny he
comes in to save him while sending their
location for help native anita are
paralyzed from st. squirt but he can
only activate the cork after he tastes
the victim's blood which means he's
probably a walking vat of STDs saying
goes to kill EDA again but this time is
saved by Totoro ki Todoroki had come to
the city as a part of his internship
with his dad and got me tortillas
location so he went to check it out
Victoria was paralyzed by stain and
recovered so he ALP started roki fight
against stain but then gets paralyzed
again we learned that Totoro he had made
peace with his mom and now accepts this
flame cork he took the internship with
his dad because he can learn a lot from
him but he hasn't forgiven him and he
doesn't plan to the episode 17 it is
able to finally move again just in time
to save photo Doki who's about to take a
heavy shot him and mediodía are able to
knock Stan unconscious and time up
endeavour Anchorage Reno finish off the
Noma that they were fighting with so
grant arena's starts heading over to me
dodea meanwhile endeavour blows off the
head of a second nomu leaving just one
left who starts to fly away
gran torino finds me dodea right before
the last no moon flies in and tries to
take away me dodea staying is able to
break from his bindings and kill the
nomu showing that he isn't aligned with
the league of villains he delivers a
rousing speech dripping with animosity
and determination and then passes out
episode 18 the next day the Chief of
Police Kenji soo tegami tells them that
they shouldn't have been fighting
without permission from Pro heroes
because of this the story is instead
told that endeavour apprehended stain
and nobody knows that the students
helped jump on over to all my who gets a
call from gran torino where they disgust
at the master of shigaraki is presumed
to be all for one all for one is the
villain that killed all mites master and
delta severe wound to all my on his
abdomen stains rousing speech got posted
online and is starting to gain traction
amongst villains who support his
ideologies episode
all the internships are still going on
while midoriya is recovering in the
hospital we jump over to Suey who is
working under sulky as a naval hero
tagging along you sulky subordinate
Sidious who is helping show a soui the
ropes silky is trapped by some smugglers
so Sidious and a sewer you have to go
and try and stop them but the aqua
villain in Smith gets the upper hand
before he can do anything sulky Pines
where they are and apprehends the
villain episode 20 the internships are
coming to a close and once back mediodía
talks with all my all my tells him about
the villain all for one who has the
ability to take and give quirks to
people we learned that all-4-one had a
little brother who is small and sickly
but had a strong sense of justice since
he thought he was quark Lassalle for one
pass down a quark to stock power but his
brother had a hidden quark that allowed
him to pass down quarks so when he
combined it with the ability to stock
power one-for-all was born the younger
brother was defeated by all for once so
he passes down his power and hopes that
the future generations would gain enough
strength to defeat him because all-4-one
had accumulated somebody quirks he
doesn't age and is close to invincible
so almighty explains that the day will
come where Methodius will have to fight
him mobility is on board with this as
long as all might is there but it
doesn't seem like that's gonna be the
case episode 21 once back from the
internships the students have to prepare
for final exams after the written
portion they're split up into teams of
two and assigned a teacher that they're
gonna have to fight Methodius teamed up
with bak ago going against all my the
first fight is Kirishima and sato versa
mentos where they can't keep up with the
stamina so the students fail episode 22
octopus I'm almost defeats a soui on
toka Yami by summoning a giant clone of
himself
what can we they use a plan to have dark
shadow sneak handcuffs onto ectoplasm
allowing them to pass a test Eva and O
judo take on power loader for their
tests where EDA launches oshio dope-ass
power loader to the escape gate passing
the test as well now we take a look at
Toto Doki and yoyo dozous who are going
against her Eraserhead
yeah Yoda Zhu has been having confidence
issues so when she devises a plan to
subdue Eraserhead he allows himself to
be caught because he's a big old softie
episode 23 brooded okay now Yama go gets
13 where a Yamazaki by asking if she
likes me don't yet although she was
flustered she still uses her training
from the internship to cup 13 ashido in
common Adi failed when they run out of
time after being countered by the
principal who uses insane predictions to
slow them down
good angira takedown present Mikan their
test with the help of some creepy
crawlers
Kota controls Shoji acts as a
distraction against snipe allowing
kagaku dates to sneak up and cuffin mean
that that gets his time to shine against
midnight after she puts eddo to sleep he
uses his quirk to subdue her and then
carry Seto to the escape gate and
finally it's time for me 30 and Baku go
to face up against all my in their tests
episode 24 the start of the fight is
really rough because my coogo is
obsessed with fighting head on while
Midori is constantly trying to run away
they finally agree to work together and
set up a trap for all might with my
daughter you using baka goes gauntlet to
hit him with an explosion then they make
a break for the gate bakur ghost starts
injuring himself while buying me DoDEA's
some time so all might knocks him
unconscious to prevent further harm
Midori it hurts his back as well but
still Lance a solid punch on all my
twitch brings all my to his limits miss
buys me dodea enough time to grab aku go
and carry him through the gate in the
last scene we see some new villains
joining the league because of stains
inspiration episode 25 the students are
informed that they're gonna be going to
the woods for their summer camp so they
go to a shopping mall to prepare for
their trip they all split up in Midori
as alone and just so happens to run into
she get Aki who threatens to kill people
in the mall if they don't talk
well talking with him she gerak he comes
to the conclusion that the reason he
hates stayin a media so much is because
of all my any wants to kill him even
more now
Rudo doc has seized them which cues she
get Aki's exit they alert the police and
look for him but are unable to track him
down in the last scene there's a
sinister doctor who is talking with the
newly revealed all-4-one well for one is
happy about she Gaddafi's newfound
conviction and reveals that he is
planning on making shigaraki his
successor and as soon as I heard that I
realized that the only thing I hate more
than intros is outros